à quelques semaines du centenaire du
concours miss france qui devrait se
tenir le 19 décembre prochain en direct
du puy-du-fou sylvie tellier on a
dévoilé encore un peu plus sur cette
cérémonie spéciale pour la première fois
ce sont une trentaine de miss france qui
vont ouvrir cette élection s'il ya deux
ans le comité avait eu l'idée de
composer un jury 100% féminin avec line
renaud en tant que présidente bonsoir la
france
bonsoir les chiens cette année et pour
marquer les 100 ans sylvie tellier avait
décidé de composer un jury 100% ancienne
miss pour juger les 29 nouvelles
prétendantes au titre
un jury présidé par iris me tonnard
couronnée miss france et miss univers
2016 parmi elles on retrouvera milliers
de fabry patricia barzyk nathalie
marquay mareva georges linda hardy sonia
rolland elodie gossuin et enfin flora
thorel une émission avec beaucoup de
monde que prévu
sauf peut être le public réponse avec
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
dans trois semaines
alors miss france un jury composé à 100%
d'anciennes miss bonne idée alors
j'avais pas j'avais mal vu yakan la
taille marquée content oui linde a dit
que je kiffe à ce qu'ils pensent sonia
rolland jeu l'adorent elodie gossuin
j'adore flow rap une grêle je connais je
la connais un peu et comme ça loin de
visu on peut pas dire que je n'aime pas
j'aime plutôt même beaucoup les
magnifiques et yanis missionnaire c'est
la présidente parce qu'elle était miss
univers et oui elle a déjà fait un bond
après get back fabrique
la patricia barzyk olé mais cohérent il
ya mareva georges donc il ya du beau
monde le sait bien c'est mal et c'est
pas mal c'est pas la méga de fabrice ars
en ré bonne femme
oui même les chats barzic aussi
l'attraper alors dit alors le sus le
trou d'abord on n'a pas arrêté de dire
que ça n'allait pas se faire vivre ça
c'est donc déjà ce serait bien celui
malgré tout avec le confinement avec
locaux vides ça c'est très courageux
nourrir pourquoi par sms pour son
anniversaire du lourd il manie se
prépare pour nous voilà donc on verra
des gravières ça c'est déjà magnifique
sera le seul homme à présent lors de la
cérémonie
alors moi je trouve ça bien il ya le
gars qu'on voit aussi que pour 1000
points wii wii sur yagg bar il jettera
les thématiques et le gars tous les os
ouais tu sais faire fonctionner le 19
ans parce que tu es bien sympa avec les
chocolats lindt et toblerone tous athées
comme lé bon tu vas venir quand même
terrain
alors ça il s'appelle bomag baumann
s'appelle ça peut être pas le nom mais
tout s'appelle bowman a très bien comme
le disait isabelle pour le côté
justement historique c'est à dire bien
sûr un hommage donc on voit ses
anciennes mise à jour qui ont fait
partie de l'histoire de miss france
c'est une sorte d' une sorte de marque
donc ça marche tu nous as très bien
d'abord premièrement et deuxièmement on
a toujours dit que c'était sexy ce que
c'était à ma théorie que c'était un
million pour les femmes ben non moi je
trouve que justement ces demis qui ont
fait partie de l'histoire miss france
ben ouais elle doit bon moi je trouve ce
mois ci dans la vie elles sont très
fiers d'avoir été ni fruit de nombreux
coloris mais oui mais non voilà ça c'est
vraiment ça c'est assez en faire trop
mais oui alors pas là les voilà
pernikoff n'avoir pas que les produits
saab mais on est d'accord ça va en faire
trop toi tu veux donner la réponse est
plus à faire tout ça manque de paille et
là si cette année et cette année 500
milles
lyon reuters le jury le jury les jurés
l'égérie sexy de la diversité il y avait
alain delon il à dire des grands acteurs
originaux jean-claude non il a regardé
une liste un peu d'années donc la
biomasse gens très bien sympa moi moi je
souhaite voir un gars de réunir que des
os il ya clairement une démarche
féministe derrière ça comme dit
géraldine parce que le concours aux
mises en contrôle écrit t soit disant
misogyne le féministe c'est pas exclure
les hommes et l'aîné s'est assurée ces
incluant les hommes et les femmes ce qui
est normal et je trouve ça complètement
ringarde très franchement mais la série
la féministe mais ça je les vois je n'ai
pas peur de le dire je suis c'est le
même groupe de production et je ferme ma
gueule et je dirais je trouve que c'est
de la merde
l'idée de rappeler les anciennes miss
moi je trouve ça très bien en revanche
l'idée de faire du féminisme comme ça
être penser que les féministes parle au
nom de toutes les femmes 6 à 7 nouvelles
et match très bien aussi qu'il ya des
hommes qui regardent d'autres femmes
pour juin tu produire à l'île tudy
[Musique]
chérie je vous dire ce qui s'est passé
jeudi aux téléspectateurs ils sont dits
tout le monde nous menace pandémique
on n'a plus droit de faire des petits
tout ça et si on faisait un jury sont
pour sow un féminin mes frères on t'a vu
arriver en over bord pour des cons non
mais ce rigoler là quand c'est trop
voyant vont arrêter de nous prendre pour
des cons
il s'agit met un petit peu moi je pense
qu'il aurait dû faire un jury comme à
même de menacer un peu tous ces mesures
ni chaussures ils ont voulu faire un
truc qui n'est pas le public
avant il y avait anthony delon enfin
de la lingerie ça donne à peu le
rayonnement international à l'épreuve
on y avait aux etats-unis montré une
image avec un de l'eau c'est pas ceux
avec mig et de fabrice qu'on va passer
sur la jada on n'a rien contre mu à
turin contre elle mais supprime mélangé
avec justement j'aurais dû mater le gall
fabry et peut-être fabrice muguette
paillé mal de soubresauts dans les
débats et cliquez ici du coup et de se
casser la fée subite est liée à une
acemis ses chouchous tu sais l'ex miss
france comme ça dans le jury a souhaité
y ait pas de remous comme ça
oui mais alors le jury vous le savez en
général est interviewé pour ces
inscriptions
c'est ce que là c'est pas aussi une
façon de mieux contrôler la
communication autant ciel scandaleux
mais seront ils hésitent pour des villes
et des frais pour des rats ou fin une
fois le pondéral ou faux oui moi je
voudrais au contraire justement c'est
bien d'avoir ces femmes qui était
devancé de la finir par ce dlc sa marque
d'honneur sur sur la 100e
c'est hyper intéressant on en plus des
demis qui sont un peu plus âgés
franchement c'est ce tunnel mais il
s'agit du couple et les deux changes la
parité il faut quelque chose de plus
éclectique de plus populaire était déjà
d'avoir trop c'est juste une haine je
peux finir il va déjà y avoir trempé a
les pieds arrêtés vous engueuler vous
m'expliquer
je n'ai jamais eu les premiers ce qu'ils
vont venir sur le plateau il ya 38 ans
et bon jeu suffisant pas la peine
d'avoir injurieuse et on va terminer
avec toi je regarde s'il vous plaît il
vient d'ouvrir les yeux à peine deux
heures d'émission quoi il a évidemment
une vraie personne a invité ses thèmes
abordés pas possible de refaire un jury
hour est franchement voilà et c'est très
dommage effectivement au moins 50 50
pour ce crime et l'identité des
assaillants
c'est je le dirai dans mon article
demain parce que j'aurai un article
celle journal j'ai pas écrit le titre ce
sera
on nous prend pour des rallyes voilà les
séries